[Music]
next to Jesus himself the Virgin Mary
may be the most honored person in the
history of Christianity most Christians
especially Roman Catholics and Eastern
Orthodox venerate hers the mother of God
the woman best placed to intercede with
her son in behalf of sinful people since
the 1960's there have been several
reports of Mary appearing to large
numbers of Christians and yet Mary has
often been controversial during the
fifth century Christians debated whether
it was proper to call her God's mother
it took a church council to settle that
question and during the Reformation of
the sixteenth century
Protestants criticized veneration of and
prayer to Mary this topic continues to
divide Catholics and Protestants when
you look at the New Testament Mary is
not nearly as prominent as her later
history might suggest in fact even in
the Gospels there are hints of an
ambivalent or even negative attitude
towards her it's in the early Christian
Apocrypha that Mary becomes the leader
among the Saints apocryphal texts tell
the story of her birth and emphasize her
absolute virginal purity and holiness
they present her as having special
access to divine knowledge through her
son Jesus they promote her is able to
intercede with God on behalf of ordinary
people and they describe the
circumstances of her death or her
falling asleep or her assumption that is
apocryphal texts first suggest that
Mary's death differed from that of other
people the apocryphal texts suggest also
that Christians with heretical
tendencies may have been the pioneers in
giving the Virgin a special role in
human salvation as we
scene one thing that apocryphal Gospels
do is fill in gaps in what the New
Testament tells us and when it comes to
Mary there are plenty of such gaps to
fill the earliest Christian author Paul
once refers to Christ as having been
born of a woman but he does not give
that woman's name nor does he say
anything more about her or Jesus's birth
so we have to turn to the Gospels and
they're the earliest gospel mark also
has little to say about the mother of
Jesus and what he does say suggests
problems mark provides no account of
Jesus's birth at all he does say that a
small group of women witnessed the
crucifixion of Jesus and then found the
empty tomb among these women are Mary
Magdalene and another Mary who is called
the mother of James and Joseph earlier
in the gospel mark names James and
Joseph as among Jesus's brothers so
could this be the mother of Jesus if so
why does it mark all her that in chapter
3 of mark the author tells us how
Jesus's mother and brothers came to find
and restrain him because they have heard
that he's insane when they show up
outside where Jesus is teaching he asks
who are my mother and my brothers
gesturing to the people listening he
answered here are my mother and my
brothers
whoever does the will of God is my
brother and sister and mother this
anecdote suggest that there was some
estrangement between Jesus and his
family or that Mark and his community
had ambivalent feelings about the mother
and brothers of Jesus the picture of
Mary in the Gospel of John is more
complicated this gospel never mentions
her name calling her simply the mother
of Jesus and like mark John does not
tell about Jesus's birth near the start
of the gospel she appears with her son
at a wedding in Cana when the hosts run
low on wine the mother points us out to
Jesus and he currently replies woman
what
concern is that to you and me
nonetheless Jesus does turn water into
wine saving the party and providing the
first sign of his divine nature at the
end of the gospel the mother of Jesus
appears at the foot of the cross as he's
dying Jesus sees her and one of his
disciples whom the gospel called the
disciple whom he loved Jesus tells them
to consider themselves mother and son
and the author says that the Beloved
Disciple took the mother into his home
in the Gospel of John Mary appears at
the beginning and the end of Jesus's
ministry at first is someone whom Jesus
rebukes and finally as someone he
clearly loves Matthew and Luke however
clearly called Jesus's mother Mary and
they have stories of Jesus's birth as
we've seen these stories differ in their
details but both claim that Mary was
betrothed to Joseph that she was a
virgin and that she gave birth to Jesus
in Bethlehem Luke gives Mary the greater
role unlike in Matthew where Joseph is
the main character in the birth
narrative Luke highlights Mary Mary
interacts with the angel Gabriel and she
speaks like a prophet delivering a major
discourse praising God known as the
Magnificat from its first words in Latin
it's Luke that tells how Jesus and his
family visited Jerusalem when Jesus was
twelve years old after Joseph and Mary
lose track of Jesus and then find him in
the temple Jesus says did you not know
that I must be in my father's house the
author says his mother treasured all
these things in her heart a suggestion
that mary has special insight into her
son's divine mission the author of Luke
also wrote the Acts of the Apostles and
there he includes Mary among the early
followers of Jesus who gathered in
Jerusalem after Jesus ascended into
heaven that's Mary's last appearance in
the story of Jesus and the early church
you can see that the new testament
picture of mary is complicated and
raises questions some episodes suggest
tension between Jesus and Mary or
between Jesus and Mary and his brothers
on the other hand Luke presents Mary as
something like a prophet and he suggests
that she has a unique understanding of
her son it's possible that these New
Testament stories recall real problems
between Jesus and his family or between
early Christians and their own families
or perhaps the authors of these Gospels
differed on how much of a role they
believed that Jesus's blood relatives
did or should play in the Christian
movement should Mary Jesus's mother and
James his brother have special Authority
because of their family relationship to
Jesus in addition to being ambiguous
Mary's appearances in the New Testament
also provoke questions who was Mary
really why was she chosen to be Jesus's
mother and what happened to her after we
last see her around the time of Jesus's
ascension and if she was like a prophet
and had special knowledge of her son as
Luke suggests did she ever exercise
leadership among the early Christians
these are the questions that ancient
apocryphal texts try to answer we've
already looked at the earliest
apocryphal texts that deals with Mary
the proto gospel of James which is from
the middle of the second century this
text fills in the gaps about Mary's
background and it exalts her purity
virginity and holiness we learned from
this work that Mary's own birth was
miraculous her parents Anna and Yeo
Hakeem were unable to have a child but
God heard their pray prayers and gave
them Mary Anna and yo Akeem dedicated
Mary to God and she grew up secluded in
the temple weaving and praying and
receiving food from an angel only when
she turned 12 did she leave the temple
and come under the protection of Joseph
and elderly widower
the proto gospel strongly emphasizes
Mary's virginity before and after the
birth of Jesus when her pregnancy is
discovered she and Joseph demonstrate
their purity through drinking a special
potion later after Jesus's birth when
Salome doubts that Mary is a virgin and
examines her to be certain Salome's hand
burns and begins to fall off until she
repents and is healed this strong focus
on Mary's virginity probably reflects
three things first the author is
defending Mary against non Christians
who claimed that Jesus was not born of a
virgin but that he was the product of
some illicit sexual liaison no the proto
gospel says Mary was truly a virgin
second it promotes Mary as a model for
Christian virgins beginning with Paul
some Christian leaders encouraged
zealous Christians not to get married
but instead to remain celibate and
devote their lives to God Mary is the
chief exemplar of such purity and
devotion third and above all the gospel
glorifies Mary as exceptionally pure and
sacred she was after all the means by
which God Himself entered the world Mary
too has a divine quality growing up in
the temple she is herself a sacred
temple the proto gospel of James was
hugely popular and its presentation of
Mary's birth and childhood became
authoritative later apocryphal works
sometimes changed a few details but the
basics of Mary's story in the proto
Gospel endured as known facts for
Christians all over the world
scholars are not quite sure when Mary
next appears in apocryphal literature
that's because there are several
Christian works from the 2nd and 3rd
centuries that feature a woman named
Mary among Christ's closest disciples
and the question is which Mary is this
for example in the
Full Gospel according to Thomas Peter
objects to the presence of Mary among
the disciples he wants Jesus to send her
away because as he says females are not
worthy of life but Jesus replies that he
will guide Mary to make her male because
females who make themselves male will
enter the kingdom of heaven in the view
of this gospel and many other ancient
sources ideal humanity is male and Jesus
says that even women can aspire to
achieve a state of maleness or consider
the apocryphal gospel according to Mary
here Mary tells the male disciples about
special revelations that she has
received from Christ
once again Peter challenges Mary and
Andrew joins him in disputing whether
Jesus would give special insights to a
woman the disciple Levi however defends
Mary and says that Jesus loved her more
than the male disciples who is this Mary
nearly all scholars believe that she's
Mary Magdalene a disciple of Jesus who
appears in all the Gospels and who
appears prominently in stories of
Jesus's resurrection in the New
Testament Gospels
it's Mary Magdalene who usually
discovers that Jesus's tomb is empty on
Easter morning and yet the historian
Steven shoemaker the world's leading
scholar of the virgin mary in ancient
Christianity points out that these and
other texts do not actually say that
this Mary is Mary Magdalene perhaps
she's actually Mary of Nazareth the
mother of Jesus after all in the New
Testament Gospel of Luke it's the Virgin
Mary who treasures everything about
Jesus in her heart and it's the Virgin
Mary who speaks like a prophet and who
gathers with the Apostles in Jerusalem
after the Ascension maybe it's this
picture of Mary the mother of Jesus as
prophetic and dwelling with the apostles
that these apocryphal texts build upon
for my part I agree with most other
scholars that the Mary of the Gospels of
Thomas and Mary is Mary Magdalene
rather than marry the virgin and so I
will not discuss those texts more in
this lecture but it's good to be aware
that it's possible that these Gospels
illustrate changing views of Mary the
mother of Jesus it's interesting that
both of them depict Mary as in conflict
with Peter who challenges her Authority
and not only this both the Gospels of
Thomas and of Mary contain ideas that
other Christians considered heretical
one rather mysterious apocryphal work
does certainly feature the Virgin Mary
engaging in something of an argument
with Peter it's called the questions of
Bartholomew and it survives in Greek
Latin and Slavonic this work takes place
after the resurrection of Jesus and it
portrays the disciples of having lots of
questions about Jesus heaven and hell
and salvation at one point Mary the
mother of Jesus joins the group and the
disciples want to ask her how it is that
she conceived and gave birth to the Son
of God Peter and John are both too
intimidated by Mary to ask her and so
Bartholomew steps up and does so as you
may know Bartholomew is one of jesus'
twelve apostles but he is mentioned only
briefly in the New Testament Mary says
that she's afraid to speak of this
mystery because if she does fire will
come out of her mouth and destroy the
world then she and Peter dispute who
should lead the group in prayer but
unlike in the Gospels according to
Thomas and Mary Peter does not reject
Mary instead Peter says that as the
tabernacle that once contained God Mary
should lead the prayer but Mary says
that Peter as the pillar of the church
should lead after this goes on for a bit
Mary leads the prayer later in the text
Peter and Mary again argue this time
over who should ask Jesus a question
once again Peter insists that Mary
should and Mary says the Peter should
tired of all this Bartholomew asks the
question so in the quest
of Bartholomew Peter and Mary argue over
who should lead but in this case each
humbly defers to the other
in addition Mary does tell the disciples
about the vision that revealed to her
that she would conceive and give birth
to Christ and as she warned fire comes
out of her mouth and it looks like it
will destroy the world until Jesus
intervenes to stop it the questions of
Bartholomew looks a lot like the gospel
of Mary in both texts mary has special
revealed knowledge that she shares with
the male apostles and she engages in
disputes with Peter but with a
difference here Peter doesn't criticize
Mary he defers to her could the
questions of Bartholomew show that the
Mary of the gospel of Mary is in fact
the Virgin Mary
rather than Mary Magdalene probably not
although we can be fairly certain that
the gospel of Mary comes from the second
century we have no clue about the date
of the questions of Bartholomew it may
be as late as the 6th century in fact
the way that Mary interacts with the
disciples and the questions of
Bartholomew looks lot looks a lot more
like what we see in Apocrypha about the
Virgin Mary from the 3rd and 4th
centuries these are Apocrypha that talk
about Mary's Dormition or her falling
asleep the event that preceded her rise
to heaven a large number of stories
hymns and sermons from late antiquity
and the early Middle Ages described the
last days of Mary's life and they tell
how Mary's soul and body were specially
and miraculously transported to paradise
so that Mary's body was not left in the
ground to suffer corruption and decay
these numerous texts differ in many
respects but they share the fundamental
conviction that as the pure vessel that
had once contained the Son of God
Mary's body could not suffer the same
death and decay that any ordinary body
would moreover as God's mother Mary
enjoys a special relationship with the
Lord one that gives her knowledge of
mysteries beyond that of any other
person
and that enables her to intercede on
behalf of human beings with her divine
son it would take multiple lectures to
go through all of this material so
instead we'll consider two early
apocryphal texts which illustrate two
basic streams of traditions about Mary's
Dormition first the book of Mary's
repose may be from as early as the third
century and every it represents what's
called the palm of the Tree of Life
traditions as the name suggests these
narratives usually feature a palm branch
from the Tree of Life a symbol of
resurrection and they were especially
popular in Western Christianity second
the six books Dormition apocryphon
likely originated in the fourth century
and it represents what's called the
Bethlehem traditions as the name
suggests these narratives take place
primarily in and around Bethlehem let's
look at each of these in turn
the book of Mary's repose was composed
originally in Greek but only fragments
of a Greek text survive instead we have
the complete text only in an ethiop ik
translation the Ethiopian you scripts
are from the 14th and 15th centuries but
Syriac fragments from the 5th century
help us to verify that the ethiopia safe
Phillipe reserves the Greek text that it
translated the book opens with a great
angel appearing to Mary and announcing
that she soon will die the angel gives
her a book which he instructs her to
give to the Apostles before her death in
later similar versions of this narrative
the angel gives Mary a palm branch hence
these texts being called part of the
palm traditions but here in the earliest
version we have it's a book when Mary
asks the angel his name he says it's a
secret it turns out that this angel is a
manifestation of Jesus himself and Jesus
starts to reminisce with Mary about his
childhood he recalls an incident
from his infancy when he and his parents
had to flee to Egypt to escape the
murderous plots of King Herod along the
way the family got tired and hungry and
Jesus recalls that Joseph complained at
some length and even lost faith that
little Jesus was divinely conceived
Joseph said very strangely but maybe he
got drunk one night and had sex with
Mary and doesn't remember it but then
Joseph cheered up and proclaimed that
Jesus was conceived by the Holy Spirit
scholars are not sure what to make of
this bizarre passage anyway the angel
Jesus reminds Mary of how the Holy
Family was miraculously fed by a date
palm that lowered itself to enable them
to eat its fruit the angel Jesus then
reveals to Mary great mysteries above
all a secret prayer that will enable her
soul after she has died to pass by the
rulers of this cosmos and ascend to
heaven Jesus describes the chief demonic
power of our cosmos as a beast with the
body of a lion and the tail of a snake
all this sounds very similar to Gnostic
and other heretical or marginally
Orthodox texts from the 2nd and 3rd
centuries some of which took the view
that the Old Testament God was a false
and evil God who had rebelled against
the true higher god of the universe many
of these sources claim that this cosmos
is ruled by evil forces that look like
animals that after death our souls must
ascend past these powers to get to
heaven and that you need to know certain
prayers and passwords to get by them
here we see again that these early
traditions about Mary are not
necessarily fully Orthodox shortly
before Mary is to die all the Apostles
gathered to where she lives in Jerusalem
because the Apostles are scattered all
over the world preaching the gospel they
must be transported there miraculously
on clouds after prayers and discussion
it's time for Mary to die she dresses in
special garments and lies down
Christ arrives with many angels and he
takes Mary's soul and gives it to
Michael the Archangel Mary's soul is
said to be a perfect form but its body
was both male and female and
nevertheless one being similar to every
body and seven times white that is its
supremely white as both male and female
and yet one and completely white Mary's
soul represents humanity without sin
humanity before the fall of Adam and Eve
completely one both male and female and
entirely pure the apostles prepare
Mary's body for burial and they place it
on a stretcher and carry it in a in a
procession to her tomb the Jews tried to
attack the funeral present procession
kill the Apostles and burn Mary's body
angels protect the procession from the
attacking Jews but one of the Jewish
priests is able to touch the stretcher
when he does his hands become severed
from his arms and they hang from the
stretcher until Peter heals him a few
days after Mary's body is buried Christ
returns and takes her body he reunites
it with her soul and places Mary near
the Tree of Life in paradise and so
Mary's body and soul are both assumed
into paradise but the book of Mary's
repose does not stop there Mary and the
Apostles are then permitted to see the
sufferings of sinners in hell the damned
people cry out to Mary Mary
we deceit you Mary light and the mother
of light Mary life and the mother of the
Apostles Mary golden lamp you who carry
every righteous lamp Mary our master and
the mother of our master Mary our queen
seats your son to give us a little rest
the apostle
scorn this request why didn't the Damned
listen to them when they were alive but
Jesus decides to give the damned three
hours of relief from their sufferings
every Sunday because of the tears of
Michael the Apostles and his mother Mary
here we see the idea that Mary can
intercede for sinful human beings and
pure procure from her son relief for
those who suffer the book concludes with
the Apostles returning to earth and Mary
seated on a throne in paradise she truly
is as she was acclaimed a queen possibly
this author has identified Mary with the
Queen like woman who appears in the book
of Revelation as the mother of a special
child in this remarkable apocryphal text
from the 3rd century we find key
elements of how Christian saw Mary in
late antiquity she has special esoteric
knowledge of mysteries which Christ has
shared with her her soul and body are
pure and spotless she therefore does not
die as other people do instead she lies
down and sleeps at God's command and her
soul and body are taken to paradise and
sinful human beings can ask her to
intercede in their behalf with Christ
some of these elements appear also in
the six books Dormition apocryphon from
the 4th century it gets its name because
it's divided into six parts called books
like the book of Mary's repose the six
books was written in Greek but the
original Greek does not survive in this
case we have a serious serious Latian in
multiple manuscripts from the 5th and
6th centuries the six books is the
earliest of a number of narratives about
Mary's Dormition that center around
Bethlehem and Jerusalem and it's likely
that it reflects the growing piety
directed towards Mary that developed in
the Holy Land during the fourth century
the six books
opens with Mary living in Jerusalem and
frequently going to the tomb of Jesus to
pray the Jews are offended by this
behavior and they persuade the Roman
governor to outlaw these visits so Mary
relocates to a house that she has in
Bethlehem where she lives with three
virgin attendants there in anticipation
of her impending death all the Apostles
gathered to Mary when each one arrives
he kisses Mary's breast and knees the
breast where Jesus nursed and the knees
on which he sat these acts of veneration
may indicate that Christians were
beginning to perform such acts of
veneration of Mary in their own worship
lives
now Mary starts performing miracles
especially healings Mary heals people
who are blind and deaf and she casts out
demons by praying over people making the
sign of the Cross and sprinkling them
with water the author says that women in
particular come from far and near to be
healed by the Virgin including daughters
of kings and imperial officials large
crowds travel from Jerusalem to
Bethlehem Mary attracts such attention
that the Jews persuade the Roman
governor to arrest her but Mary and the
Apostles avoid capture by flying along
with Mary's bed to her house in
Jerusalem once there Mary continues to
perform miraculous healings and in fact
people start to experience the Virgin's
divine power in other places as far away
as Rome Mary appears to people in these
distant places the first record of
Marian apparitions a phenomenon that
continues to the present day Jewish
addition to Mary also persists as in the
book of Mary's repose a droop a Jew
tries to attack a stretcher on which
Mary lies and his hands are severed from
his body but in this version Mary is
still alive and in this case Mary heals
the man herself also as in the book of
Mary's repose Christ Michael and the
other angels take Mary's soul and body
to Paradise so that she does not decay
in her tomb in contrast to the book of
Mary's repose however the six books
Dormition apocryphon shows clearly that
some Christians are now venerating Mary
with scheduled festival days the text
instructs its readers to honor Mary on
certain days and it associates Mary
especially with agricultural prosperity
as well as healings the book includes
the offering of bread in the name of the
Virgin this last point is especially
significant because in the late 300s a
Christian bishop named epifanio's based
on the island of Cyprus wrote about
Christians who he said made bread
offerings to the Virgin Mary he called
these Christians
Koller idioms and he criticized their
veneration of Mary as inappropriate in
the case of a human being he accused
them of worshipping Mary as if she were
God but epifanio's did not like much of
what Christians around him were doing
especially the emerging cult of the
Saints during the 4th century Christians
developed a set of practices in which
they would communicate with and have
fellowship with deceased saints
especially the apostles and martyrs
Christians would honor their remains or
relics worship at their tombs and ask
them to intercede with God in their
behalf veneration of Mary which we see
in the six books Dormition apocryphon
was part of this growing trend Mary
however held a special place among the
Saints for she had given birth to the
Son of God himself and so she was known
in Greek as the Theotokos the one who
gave birth to go
or the mother of God as such her body
was holy and pure and so it did not die
normally but went straight to paradise
likewise Mary was particularly well
suited to petition her son Christ in
behalf of sinful or sick human beings in
the 420s mist aureus the bishop of the
imperial capital of Constantinople
denied that Mary should be called the
mother of God God can't be born he
argued he has no mother instead Mary
gave birth to the human Jesus with whom
the Son of God
United other bishops had problems with
mysterious teachings for theological
reasons but many ordinary Christians
rebelled against the idea that Mary was
not the mother of God
at a major church council at Ephesus in
431 mist aureus was condemned and Mary
was declared the mother of God devotion
to Mary flourished even more in the
following decades and centuries and in
1950 Pope Pius the 12th defined as
official Catholic doctrine the
Assumption of the Virgin's body and soul
into heavenly glory putting the full
authority of the church behind an idea
that we first find in apocryphal texts
of the 3rd and 4th centuries